let's go next to our caller from the 267
area code 267 what's your name where are
you calling from I did it my name is
William
I'm Victor on the show thanks I wanted I
want to talk to you about immigration
yes so you talked about you talked about
how the right smears the left by saying
the left supports over borders right but
I think those both sides just view this
subject differently okay so I think the
right views the left as proof from
borders because they're generally soft
on enforcing deportations like this when
people come here illegally the left is
generally not as fast to support them to
be deported if that makes any sense so
what would be an example of that who are
you talking about people who have done
what exactly I don't have any specific
examples I just have a general feeling
of like that's based off of a bunch of
let's mine commentators and people on
the left that I've spoken to personally
that's the general vibe they don't
really want people to be deported like
like parentheses I've heard on on your
show how you support people being
deported they've done a violent crime
but they've already come here illegally
so I think just coming here is enough
for deportation because they don't
belong to they were born here they don't
haven't done so listen labour will give
you let me give you what I think is the
predominant view there is no doubt that
there are immigration activists who say
if you've come here illegally but
haven't committed any other crime it
should be treated sort of like a civil
infraction it should be a ticket or
whatever you said you should not be
deported okay I don't think that's the
predominant view my understanding of the
predominant view on the left is there's
no question that countries are allowed
to have borders and immigration law and
enforce immigration law the disagreement
comes in that the priority should not be
as a solution to go out and proactively
find people who have committed no other
crime other than being here illegally
and deport those people when there are
so many other things that should be done
first like for example we
be looking at overstayed visas and we
should be looking at technology on the
border and we should be looking at a
path to citizenship for daca to make
sure that those people who came here
through no choice of their own there's a
lot of priorities and then even beyond
that there are other criminal priorities
within the United States that are higher
priorities than just finding people who
are here illegally and deporting them so
I'm sure you're right there are people
who don't want undocumented immigrants
to be deported at all I don't think
that's the primary view I think the
primary view is that choosing to make
the priority to do ice raids and just
find people who are here working hard
whatever when it was your faulty system
to begin with that allowed them to come
here to start with seems like a totally
misguided priority I think that's really
the issue oh okay well I definitely
agree with that it shouldn't be a
priority and especially since some
people been deported by accident I don't
think people should be going through you
know lists of citizens and trying to get
to the route William there's a civil
liberties issue also where for example I
don't think that if police pull you over
and you have a driver's license and you
were speeding I don't think it should be
in their purview to ask questions about
or explore your immigration status that
should not be the job of local police
for example does that mean I think
anyone should be allowed to come to the
US illegally at any time no but from a
civil liberties perspective I don't
believe that that's the job that local
police should be doing did you
understand the distinction yeah
absolutely and I agree with that as well
cool so everything you're saying all
right good well we've changed
at least on the predominant view I
appreciate the call I've got a lot of
people holding so I'm going to move on
but you know a lot of times I feel like
our disagreements are based on
misunderstanding the other person's
position not actually disagreeing about
the principle let's go next to our
caller from the three-two-three area
code caller from three to three what's
your name where are you calling from
hey there David names Josh I'm calling
from LA okay
what's going on um had kind of a strange
question for you a little bit more like
a career advice type question but if
you'll be so kind let me take a running
start of this so I've been sort of
politically politically activated back
in 2016 when I started watching people
like you and Young Turks and Klinsky
kind of never really liked politics
didn't trust politicians until I heard
about Bernie Sanders he changed
everything for me
he basically made me politically
activated I'm a professional
cinematographer living in LA and my
question for you is
I'm trying in my own way to push the
Overton Window to the left I try and
talk to friends and family about
important issues anyone I meet really at
a party like lordose my wife would say
I've ruined lots of weddings by you know
chatting up people who had political
disagreement with me um but basically my
question for you is like how in my own
way in my own sphere can I push that
window to the left and I'm not really
able or interested in doing what you do
which is being on camera
I'm a camera man myself so I'm looking
to amplify people's voices on the left
just wondering if you had any tips so
you want to amplify voices from the left
but you don't want to be on camera and
I'm guessing you don't want to be
involved in producing a show either oh
no I want to be involved in producing it
I just don't have like the wherewithal
to like go on camera and do it you do
but there's a lot of people who do what
I do but they don't they lack either the
technical skills or the business skills
or the access to the equipment to do it
so I would say partner up with someone
who does want to be on camera but lacks
the skills that you have and then now
instead of it just being one guy or gal
who has to figure this out now you've
got two people I mean one of the things
that really I've seen a lot of shows
fail not because the host has bad ideas
or is a bad communicator but I've seen
shows fail because they can't get the
tech side together they can't get it
together enough to be regularly
producing content which is what it
start building things up so I would say
partner up with someone who does want to
be on camera bring your skills to the
table I've tried that yeah I've
contacted other campaigns like I hit up
ahead guitar and through the San
Francisco one shot some content for him
pro bono I'm looking to do more stuff
like that but these campaign of course I
volunteered for jank and I volunteered
for Bernie but those campaigns have
never written me back I'm sure they get
a billion emails a day I was just
wondering if you knew of any other local
progressives or maybe not well cool but
I I don't believe I'm saying not don't
get jumped in with a candidate because
the candidate might win and then their
elected official are they losing them
they disappear really look at starting
an ongoing program with someone who who
is interested in being on camera as a
host not as a candidate you know what
I'm saying yeah yeah I think that's a
great idea yeah because then it's sort
of like it the conversation continues
over whoever and this is honestly this
is one of the problems I see with Bernie
in 2016 in 2020 I've seen it with tulsi
gabbard where channels pop up where
they're it's just about the candidate
only and then if the candidate doesn't
win all of that audience and goodwill
that you've built up kind of disappears
because it was based around a candidate
so I like the idea of building a show
either around the host or around an
issue rather than a candidate I think
that's the way to go or even broader
like about an ideology sure of course
progressive ideology okay I hope that
it's somewhat useful I appreciate the
call thing all right Josh great to hear
from you let's take a quick break if
you're holding don't hang up because I
will go right back to the phones after
this short break